welcome back to yet another tutorial on
Python with simply learn today we'll
cover what objects and classes in Python
are so previously we saw that Python is
an object-oriented programming language
so what this means is that Python is
completely focused around the presence
of an object and this is why we will
stress more today on what this object
actually means and what classes are in
relation to objects so let's begin first
we look at what an object is so in the
real world
everything tangible is an object the
table the chair your mobile phone your
laptop even you are an object and in the
similar manner in Python
since you are focusing so much on an
object and programming a round object so
every instance in python is an object
now if that is what an object is what is
a class a class is a blueprint of
similar objects so you'll have multiple
objects in programming often and all
these objects have some similar features
so a class basically holds all these
objects together and gives them a common
definition now let's better understand
this through an example
so here we are considering person as a
class now if persons our class every
person has certain features that is name
gender age irrespective of who the
person is the person has to have these
features so this is something common
shared by all the people now a person
also has a behavior and behavior
basically means the functions a person
is entitled to perform so obviously
there are a number of things that a
person can do but in this particular
case we look at just two of them which
is talk and would definitely there are
some exceptions which will not dwell
into right now so now that we saw what
features and what behavior are and how
person which is a class describes these
things let's look at what an object
would look like under this class person
so here we have two objects of the class
person our first object which is on your
left hand side has the features new
gender each and the behavior talk and
vote now every object has to have these
features because these are words defined
under the class person and in a similar
manner the object that's defined to your
right also have the same features and
the same behaviors now what is it that
makes these two objects two separate
entities then it's the value of the
features so our features name gender age
in either case has a different value for
example our first object has the name
Sam a second object has the name mia
gender is male and for a second object
gender is female age is also a different
value for both the objects now they
could have the same value that is there
could be some common features but if all
of them have the same value that
wouldn't make sense they wouldn't make
them two separate objects so to
summarize this person is a class and the
class defines the features name gender
and age it defines behaviors talk and
would and then we defined two separate
objects and gave value to the features
in these objects now let's begin to code
this example so I'll move on to PyCharm
first thing first let's create our class
so a class is created using the keyword
class and then put down the name of your
class which in our case is person
followed by colon and enter so your
class is created now once that your
class is created the next thing we need
to focus on are the features that this
class defines so the person class
defines the features name age and gender
now in our previous video on oops we saw
that the features or the members of a
class are defined using a constructor
usually so let's create a constructor
which is def in it and once you click on
init the self parameter automatically
appears self basically refers to the
object that you are passing to this
constructor or the object that is being
created when the constructor is called
now we'll give value to add three
features so our features are named
and that will have the value system
gender mail and age 22 now one thing
that we're missing out here is that we
need to remember that name gender age
all these are features of the class that
means these features are strictly tied
to an object that would be the object
that's created when this init function
is called for that particular time so
the reference to that object would be
stored in self therefore we won't just
write name equal to sam but instead self
dot name equal to sam and in a similar
manner self dot gender and self dot h so
we have defined our features of the
class person and also given it value now
next thing is you have to define the
behaviors so behaviors are implemented
through functions or we can say methods
so methods are basically functions but
the functions which are called through
an object or tied to an object are
called methods so let's define our
methods our first behavior is the talk
behavior so if the talk method is called
we just want to print out hi I am and
the value of the name attribute of the
object that's calling talk now a next
behavior to be implemented is the Voort
behavior so for that we'll create a
method vote and here we'll put in a
condition so if the age of the person is
less than 18 the person's not eligible
to vote so we'll print this out and if
the person is above 18 then we'll print
out the person is eligible to vote so if
self dot age is less than equal to 18
[Music]
I am not eligible towards actually less
than 18 if the person is 18 they are
eligible to vote sprint I am eligible
towards so the two behaviors of the
class person are implemented through
methods now now all that's left for us
to do is to create the actual object so
how do you create the object if my
object name is obj I'll write obj equal
to and then put in the type of the
object and the type of object is of
course the class now here are something
that you need to understand everything
that you create in Python is actually an
object so I'll explain this a little
more in my console so if I have a
variable say a and I give this variable
the value hundred we know that 100 is an
integer type value therefore that makes
a an integer type variable but then if I
check the type of this variable
it shows class int that means the type
of a is the integer class which makes a
an object in the similar manner if I
have another value to a say simply learn
and now if I check the type of aim we
will see that a is now an object of
class string STR is basically the short
form of string therefore everything in
Python is an object of some class and
that is how our object here obj is an
object of the type person web person is
our class so now that we have created an
object during this creation of the
object a constructor will be called and
the features of this object will be
given some value now we can use this
object to call its behaviors so this can
be done within this manner so you put in
person which is the type of our object
dot the method and within the bracket as
a parameter you can pass the object in
the similar manner we'll also call our
behavior boat
and again past obg within it now let's
run this code just pull up my console
here
run the program and as you can see here
so we created an object and the object
caught its values as mentioned in the
constructor that is in it and then we
call the table behavior or the top
method using our object obj and this
printed our first line which is hi I am
Sam and then we call the word behavior
and the word behavior the age of our
object was checked since our objects age
was greater than 18 it says I'm eligible
to vote now these two lines where we are
calling our methods can be done in a
different way instead of calling it with
the type of our object and then passing
an object we can directly call through
the object so we can have it in this way
obj dot talk of and over here for BJ dot
vote off so we must remember that in
this particular case where we are
creating classes and objects and have
this kind of a structure all these
methods are actually tied to the object
which is why we cannot just say talk off
we need an object to call it or at least
pass an object to this method let's run
the code now so it's the exact same
result works just fine now in this case
we just created one object and the
values for this object were
predetermined and just put in a
constructor now what if we want to
create two separate objects and the
values for these objects vary so in this
case so to demonstrate this we'll create
two objects just like an example
previously we'll have our first object
which is obj one now both these object
will be of course of the type person
which is a class so put that there now
every time the object is created
automatically an init method is called
so if our object needs to have separate
values what we can do is instead of
putting in predetermined values here we
can pass the values for the features of
the object in the bracket so if I want
my name to be Sam I pass Sam my gender
and the age so these are the three
values for the three features that this
object has
which will pass into the constructor or
the init method now in the init method
we need to be able to accept these
values so other than self will have one
variable which will store the value of
the name when it's passed from here
we'll stir it in variable N and for name
and the gender we'll store it in
variable G age will store in variable a
so what happens here is basically these
values that you pass with any
parentheses when you're creating your
object are sent to your init method now
in the init method we are putting down
these three variables to accept the
values so these three variables store
these three values so Sam goes to N mail
goes to G and 22 goes into a now instead
of putting in the strings here self drop
me can be equal to n so the value which
n got is now put into cell dot name and
the value which G received is put into
cell dot gender and the value which a
received will be put into self dot H so
that way we created our object and
provided a B in which we can actually
have unique values for each object so
now if we have another object say obj 2
which is also of the type person we can
put in different values into these
parentheses so sale our second object's
name is Jessie she's female and 16 years
old so now these values will go into
these variables and will be assigned to
these features so for obj1 if I say obj1
dot name the name would be Sam if I say
obj - dot name it would result in Jessie
will see that now let me just print that
out
obj one dots name and obj two dots name
so as you see although a feature is the
same we are printing the feature name in
both the cases the object to which this
feature is tied is different so the
first time it's printing name related to
object 1 and the second time it's
printing the name related to object -
now this is not what we want to show
here here
what we want to do is after creating our
two objects we'll call the methods using
these objects so obj one dot talk off
and obj one dot vote off now we'll call
the same two methods using obj - so obg
- dot talk off and obj - dot vote off
run the program and here's our output so
what happened here is obj one was
created and the three features which are
named gender and age were given the
respective values for obj one and the
similar manner will be here - also
received the values for its various
features now we used obj one to call are
two methods talk and vote at talk all we
did is print our name of the object so
the first time when we call with obj1 it
printed hi I'm Sam because Sam was the
name related to our first object and
then we call the vote method using obj1
itself so our first objects age was 22
which means it's eligible to vote and
that is what's printed here I am
eligible to vote then we call the same
two methods using obj - and got
different results so obj - his name was
printed here which is Jessie and then
Jesse is underage that she is 16 so it
printed out and not eligible to would
when obj - dot vote was called so that
is the basic crux of what objects and
classes are I hope this was clear if you
have any doubts please post them in the
comment section below and we'll
definitely get back to you if you found
this video helpful please hit the like
button below also subscribe to our
channel if you have not yet as we have a
lot more great videos coming up for you
so stay tuned and see y'all next time
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here